just nothing be glad that we've got one
under our belt and we know what the
heck's going on I was gonna say we now
know what we're doing because it was
actually you know trial by era we didn't
know what the heck we were doing well
first went out there but one thing is
for sure
hey we got along and part of that one is
the talent showed up oh my god I didn't
realize there was so much talent now I
think speaking on behalf of us when
America stars voting we don't know I
mean it no longer
we're spectators at that point because
we think do we have one thing covered
nope they go to the other way and it's
it's a surprise package hey do you
famously kissed a contestant during the
audition rounds have you kissed anyone
on the press line because I'm a willing
participant thank you so much
you know after I I'm gonna consult some
people don't get no don't go there well
I kissed her and she praised a bacteria
oh my gosh she was so gorgeous and I'm
just so excited for all that I've seen
the whole world oh they all the
incredible insanity that's gonna happen
next season it's good there's gonna be a
lot of high highs a couple of low lows
and somewhat in between